he's Clayton Kershaw the Dodgers pitcher
game one performance seven innings three
hits one earned run eleven strikeouts
the next game coming up tonight it'll be
Astros and the Dodgers at 8:20 Eastern
Clayton joins us now Congrats on Game
one what do you do all day prior to a
game when you're not pitching yeah you
know once you get out there it's okay
but it's just especially when he has so
many off days like at least there's
another game to think about host design
baseball but you know Game one
especially the way we've been playing
we've had a lot of extra off days so
it's just that's the only thing on your
mind up until the game and then you know
once the game starts you're okay but
there's some definite painting moments
before that okay but like today you have
nothing what what is your job tonight my
job tonight
cheerleader basically yeah you know
starting pitchers they you know they say
we don't do anything in between sart's
we do some stuff but yeah I mean once
the game starts it's just cheerleader
how do you help the store how would you
help Darvish tonight I really can't I
mean you know you and I have talked and
I'm you know when he first got over here
and I'm just you know I think you stuff
is unbelievable
so when he first got over here he likes
to tinker a lot and work on a lot of
different stuff and which is great
because you got so many different
weapons but I mean I told him when he
first came over here just just trust how
good your stuff is next I can't hit it
so that's really all I told him and he's
been really good and I can't take credit
for that but he's been an unbelievable
so tonight there's no way I can help I'm
just gonna watch him what's the last
time you learned a pitcher tried to
learn a pitch from another pitcher well
I tried to learn a changeup every year
every year a different grip looks good
and so I try that one out and it ends up
not working so the actual first time I
probably learned to pitch is a slider I
did that probably like 2009 or 10 and I
was I'm not here so I don't I don't
learn well I guess
but you know that it pitch is bad how
are they it's not gonna work you don't
want it in your rotation repertoire now
usually results based you know they play
catch like oh man that's awesome
then you go through the game and you get
shell so it's we had AJ Hinch the Astros
manager on last hour I just want to get
you on record I said if you have a
question for Clayton what would it be
and this is what he had to say
we got Clayton Kershaw next hour
anything you want me to ask him yeah if
you can skip it starting in five okay
Clayton are you going to skip your start
and game fun you know I do not think so
I think I'll be there but you know I
don't think he needs me to skip a start
they got some pretty good players over
there so so no fun series man that the
team is vouchers are legit I mean they
they got some guys that swing the bats
and with title and Verlander and even I
go into my colors more than they get
some guys that really throw the ball
well so we got our hands full I what was
different about Game one for you cuz
that I forget who we had on might have
been John Smoltz he said that might be
the best he's ever seen you pitch and
that's that's certainly high praise but
was there something different no I mean
I don't think so I had a pretty good
command of all my pitches so you know
maybe that doesn't happen all the time
but yeah I mean I think I was able to
throw strikes with a lot of them they
broke some and got them to swing and
miss a few times but I don't I don't
really know if there's a huge difference
are you trying to have them get
themselves out or trying to strike them
out
I never could strike anybody out I
really don't it's just when you get the
two strikes you you know the margin for
error is a little bit more so you try to
make that perfect pitch a little bit
more with these strikes but yeah I mean
when guys are sweating guys are
typically pretty aggressive off of me
and so if they want to get out and feed
a couple pitches that's great by me how
big or small is Altuve strike zone it
doesn't seem
I mean that guy is whole first of all if
you do throw it strike there's a good
chance to be swinging and getting hit on
it so that's part of the problem too but
that's uh he's a pretty incredible
hitter man just what he's able to do the
power that he's able to generate and the
pitches that he can hit I mean it
doesn't it doesn't necessarily have to
be a strike for him to hit it so it's uh
he's a very impressive player how was it
pitching in that temperature or those
temperatures it was hot you know it was
but you know a hot different you know I
don't care what you say it's not like
Texas I mean I grew up here in Dallas
and I mean it's 98 in Dallas is a lot
different than 98 in LA for some reason
so you know it wasn't too bad how many
friends are you gonna have game 5
oh just I think we have 36 of my closest
friends and family tonight Thursday and
3 so it'll be awesome you know how much
are you gonna have to shell out I mean
how many tickets are you getting and
then how many do it I got I got 40 for
the three games each game 40 for three
games and you know my wife went to Texas
A&M so you know a lot of people from
Houston that she knows or hear some of
her good friends my buddies are loyal
though my buddies have been coming they
came NLCS at World Series you know
during the regular season so they
deserve the tickets so I I got no
problem with them showing up now can
your bro how much your bros when can
they give you grief like if you get
shelled how long before they can give
you grief you know I'd like him if it
was a World Series or playoff game to
give me a day or two you know regular
regular season regular season they're on
me pretty quick for sure yeah but that's
what that's what friends are for right
oh yeah that's awesome that's why I love
going home is just you know they don't
care I play baseball I just they just
have fun giving me our time do you
notice the celebrities in the stands
there's some big names there I mean
Justin Timberlake had me that was I was
pretty awesome he's kind of my that's
like my celebrity crush a little bit I
was pretty fired up to see him up there
did you say hello no I don't know where
you're sitting I just found
trying to find them but I don't know
where he's sitting yeah but you're you
would have been able to do that in Game
two you could have gone up in the stands
and you know you weren't doing anything
he's Clayton Kershaw the Dodgers pitcher
he goes in Game five in the the
difference in pitching in Houston and
Los Angeles like everybody says the
Dodger Stadium not a hitter's ballpark
what's that like in Houston Houston is a
hitter's ballpark no doubt I mean left
field porch does feel like did that
shortstop and Houston but I mean at the
end of the day both pitchers are dealing
with it and you can't you can't worry
about it you can't let it affect how
you're gonna pitch so yeah I wouldn't be
surprised if they're a few homers and
actually games but the ball was jumping
in Game two more than Game one right
right right you know yeah I mean people
are saying the ball to juste you know
all baseball season and I'll be the
first to jump on that bandwagon because
I've given up the kind of homers so I
you know I'm all in on that philosophy
but you know at the end of the day I
always say it's like well everybody else
is dealing with it too right it's not
like it's not like I'm the only one
giving up a lot more homers so I don't
really care
homers are cool people like seeing them
so if they're doing something sneaky or
behind our back that's fine of me I
don't really care do you don't care if
the league was juicing those baseball's
on purpose no everybody's dealing with
it right I mean it's like it'd be cool
if they told us but if they are and we
don't know that everybody's dealing with
it's not like they're picking on one guy
that's okay yeah I don't know I remember
talking to Smoltz about that and he said
there would be times when like the
second baseman was hitting an opposite
field home run and he would go that's
just not right like there's certain
pitches that if you you give it up you
or you serve it up then you know that
you're gonna you're gonna pay the price
like that would frustrate if it's the
backup second baseman who takes you
opposite field well I mean I think it's
more ballpark related than anything like
you see you know Aaron judge rather than
a few homers and
last series of Houston and then Korea
Altuve those guys going deep you know to
the first or second row and Houston and
then the Yankee Stadium right field I
mean there's a lot of ballparks where
you can make the argument that the fence
itself is the reason why these home runs
are getting out of here so I yeah it is
frustrating you know the bullets I think
they've all Todd Frazier hit did you see
that one ALCS currents I mean that
you're right yeah that shouldn't be a
homer we write about with one-handed
like a flip out there Cleon he's a
strong guy and he can hit some homers
but you're right that was I would
frustrate me if I threw that pitch we
had a homer for sure Randy Johnson joins
us a couple of weeks ago and I said
what's the homerun that you know people
are going to show and you're proud of
and he said the homerun I threw to Mark
McGwire that was this like I'm bringing
it and here it is
is there a homerun that you're actually
proud you gave up like man he got all of
it question
I've given up like two or three to Stan
I think I don't think you said any of
those like eight hundred footers on to
me but it's they're pretty it's like
line drives that just they don't go down
and you look back on it's like a second
later and they're at the grandstand so
yeah he's a guy that you know you pay
money to go watch at homers that's
pretty fun and you know and judge same
thing those guys I don't face judge yet
but those guys are pretty impressive
watching it we have a wall of socks is
it out of the question maybe to get pair
of socks here next start yeah you know I
got I got you know these are non game
well i got abby wambach from the World
Cup I mean we got some socks in here
asking for Jersey and we just thought
unwashed socks would be cutted now you
know just autograph them World Series
song yeah absolutely
yeah remind me oh but if you get bombs
oh then it might be hard to own them
oh I don't want those that's
unbelievable
can't just say if you pitch good you can
have my sock I'm assuming you're gonna
pitch ball that's ask am i asking for
the socks I just don't want you to go
ahead and pitch ain't no I went 6 and
2/3 and I gave up 3 runs
those aren't wall of socks were these so
I know you have high standards here okay
well I pitch 6 and 2/3 and gave up 3
runs
you're funny my socks oh yeah I'll keep
my socks yeah other than that you're
getting them good or bad enjoy your days
off there and good luck being a
cheerleader thanks for joining us as
always in credit cards on Game one
Clayton Kershaw right there Todd your
pitcher for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]